un enrichissement historique des
milliardaires française voilà ce qu'a
permis en france la réponse à la crise
sanitaire selon les ong oxfam c'est sans
précédent en france la fortune des
milliardaires a augmenté plus rapidement
en 19 mois de pandémie quand une
décennie entière de mars 2020 à octobre
2021 la fortune des milliardaires a
augmenté de 2 136 milliards d'euros soit
une hausse de 86% 236 milliards d'euros
c'est assez d'argent pour quadrupler le
budget de l'hôpital public ou verser un
chèque de 3500 euros à chaque françaises
et français selon les estimations de
forbes la france compte 43 milliardaire
c'est quatre fois plus qu'après la crise
financière de 2009 aujourd'hui les cinq
premières fortunes de france possède
autant que les 40% des français les plus
précaires la crise sanitaire elle a
notamment permis l'ascension d'un homme
dans le classement français des
milliardaires stéphane bancel pdg du
laboratoire moderna ce dernier s'est
directement ici à la 7e place du
classement forbes selon oxfam c'est la
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte qui a
permis cet enrichissement mais aussi les
politiques fiscales appliquées pendant
ces dernières années dès juin 2020 la
banque ubs avertissez de l'impact des
mesures et des politiques monétaires des
banques centrales sur la fortune des
milliardaires avec une politique du quoi
qu'il en coûte sans condition pour faire
face à la crise les gouvernements et les
banques centrales ont permis la hausse
la plus importante de la fortune des
milliardaires jamais enregistrée la
dérégulation du marché du travail les
politiques fiscales décidées au cours
des 40 dernières années au construit une
économie au service des 1% conséquence
aujourd'hui non seulement la
contribution des plus aisés s'est
reportée sur les classes moyennes et les
populations précaires mais le
financement de notre modèle social se
retrouve affaibli dans ses
recommandations oxfam plaide notamment
pour un changement radical de politique
fiscale à savoir taxer les plus riches
par le biais de la réintroduction par
exemple d'un impôt sur la fortune une
option balayé par le ministre de
l'économie lors de ses voeux à bercy en
début d'année et déjà l'année dernière
bien sûr qu'il faut lutter contre les
inégalités laisser penser que c'est en
taxant les plus riches encore davantage
je ne pense pas que ce soit la solution
malgré les appels répétés des ong de
civils ou de personnalités publiques à
penser le monde après l'économie semble
bel et bien rester au service des plus
riches et si la pandémie chat bien joué
un rôle décisif dans l'accélération des
inégalités et dans une financiarisation
tout azimut personne ne semble décidé à
renverser la tendance